that sounds like a lot of jobs gone in
why
well there are a couple of uh factors at
play here kimberly the first of course
is the uh closure of jax which you
mentioned just now now jax was a
discount store chain that tesco opened
in 2018 specifically to take on the
german hard discounters oldie and lidl
they announced after the stock market
closed last night that of these uh 13
stores they're going to be retiring the
br jack's brand name it was named
originally after sir jack cohen the
founder of tesco all those years ago
they are going to be closing six of
those stores permanently and the rest
will be converted into uh tesco stores
that's one part of the announcement the
other that we've had this morning is
that essentially they're going to be
doing away with overnight replenishment
of stocks in 36 of its larger stores and
49 of its smaller stores and accordingly
there will be an impact on jobs now the
reason that tesco says it wants to do
this is because it can do this just as
well during the day time and uh their
argument is it will also free up staff
to spend more time on the shop floor
dealing with customer inquiries so in
total if you take the two announcements
together it means that uh getting on for
some thirteen thousand uh sorry sixteen
thousand jobs i say sixteen hundred jobs
put my teeth back in are at risk the
interesting thing though is that tesco
is also stressing that right now within
its business it has some three thousand
job vacancies and therefore it's pretty
confident that a lot of the people whose
jobs are under risk from these twin
announcements will be rehired elsewhere
during the business now the backdrop to
all of this it comes at an incredibly uh
interesting time for the uk grocery
market because two out of the
traditional big four have just changed
hands asda was obviously bought last
year by the issa brothers who built
their fortune from uh garage four courts
and then of course just before christmas
morrisons was the subject of a very
heated takeover battle between private
equity buyers it's been bought by
clayton de bilia and rice which is a
private equity firm interestingly
advised by sir terry leahy the former
tesco chief executive and now currently
run by david potts who is a former tesco
executive as well uh those businesses
have changed hands you could expect
there to be a fair bit of uh turmoil
within those businesses and a lot of
people incidentally analysts are
speculating that you could see prices
going up particularly at asda because
those businesses once they're owned by
private equity buyers they've both been
heavily uh
hocked up with debt in order for those
deals to go through well the buyers of
those businesses potentially will have
to claw back some of that repay that
debt down quickly potentially by putting
up prices and of course they have cover
to do this right now because there is
inflation in the market more generally
now potentially you'd think that would
leave tesco and sainsbury's as the two
stock market listed players a lot more
stability of ownership right now with a
lot more to play for in terms of cutting
prices and of course as i mentioned
you've got the german hard discounters
aldi and little sitting there in the
background right now it's a time of
great turmoil and shake-up in the
grocery industry and i think this is
part and parcel of that tesco really
wanting to sharpen up its act and
potentially turn the screw i think on
both asda and morrisons in particular